les re 5e' on l'a vu en depuis le début
de ce conflit n'hésitent plus à menacer
régulièrement et ouvertement les
occidentaux y compris sur des terrains
lointains comme l'espace moscou a
effectivement déclaré ce week-end que
les sanctions contre la russie pourrait
entraîner la chute de l'urss la station
spatiale internationale on en parle avec
vous sylvain rousseau bonjour sinon déjà
ce qu'il faut prendre la menace au
sérieux alors pour bien comprendre le
sens de cette menace il faut comprendre
comment fonctionne la station spatiale
la station spatiale elle orbite autour
de la terre et puis très régulièrement
il faut corriger cette orbite pour
éviter que la station spatiale tombe
c'est une opération qui sort en moyenne
11 fois par an parfois pour éviter
simplement un débris spatial qui
mettrait en danger l'intégrité de la
station et cette opération de
réhabilitation il n'y a pour l'instant
que les russes qui sont capables de le
faire il pour cela il faut évidemment
ravitailler la station régulièrement
mais le lanceur qui sert à ravitailler
cette tension cette station est
aujourd'hui sous sanctions sous
sanctions européennes japonaises
canadienne et américaine c'est à dire
toutes les autres parties prenantes de
la station spatiale donc c'est
effectivement si les russes arrête de ré
orbite et la station effectivement la
station va tomber mais c'est une arme à
double tranchant puisque lorsque le
lorsqu'une partie prenante quitte à un
programme comme celui-là est bien les
autres apprennent à faire sans lui il
est finalement remplacé il est
immédiatement remplacé la nature a
horreur du vide on sait que les
américains travaillent déjà à une
solution de remplacement depuis quelques
jours depuis quelques semaines et eu
effectivement le risque pour les russes
c'est d'être évincé du programme de la
station spatiale ce qui pour leur image
serait quelque chose d'assez dramatique
puisque cela fait plus de cinquante ans
qui lie à soi un soviétique soit un
russe sans discontinuer dans l'espace
avec les différentes stations puis
maintenant la station spatiale
internationale
ce qu'on sait en revanche de la vie à
bord c'est que pour l'instant
officiellement l'ambiance est bonne même
si les cosmonautes russes ont reçu
l'ordre de ne pas travailler aux
expériences scientifiques avec
l'astronaute allemand qu'il astronautes
européens mathias maurer on se dit aussi
que tant qu'il y a deux astronautes
russes à bord les russes ne vont
évidemment pas laisser tomber la station
mais voilà en revanche par contre ce qui
est assez amusant c'est que parmi les
deux cosmonautes russes qui sont tous
les deux nés à l'époque de l'union
soviétique il y en a un qui est né en
russie 1 qui est né en ukraine y on our
n'ose imaginer les discussions
politiques à bord du coup dur pour
illustrer la complexité aussi de ce
conflit ans poêler les programmes
spatiaux c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas eu
tendance à cet or j'ai tout de suite là
dessus c'est une autre réalité sont
impactés par et la guerre et les
sanctions
le spatial est une industrie qui est
interconnecté c'est à dire que toutes
les agences travaillent ensemble hormis
les chinois qui ne travaille pas avec
les américains par exemple mais tout le
monde travaille avec l'agencé spatiale
russe à titre d'exemple il y a les
nouveaux satellites galileo qui devait
partir un système de radionavigation
européens qui sont cloués au sol à
kourou puisque les russes ne lance plus
depuis kourou il y a trente six
satellites web britannique qui sont eux
sous scellés à baïkonour au kazakhstan
pareil parce que les russes ne veulent
pas les lancers faute de garanties du
gouvernement le britannique ces
satellites de communication ne seront
pas utilisées à des fins militaires il
ya le programme le plus emblématique de
l' agence spatiale européenne le rover
exomars censé partir lui aussi par une
fusée soyouz le 20 septembre et son
avenir est hautement compromis il ya
maintenant plusieurs solutions on parle
quand même d'un programme à 2 milliards
de dollars une fenêtre qui s'ouvre tout
les tous les deux ans dans soit les
européens cherchent une solution de
repli urgente avec les risques que cela
comporte soit on abandonne complètement
le programme soit on le maintient en vie
encore jusqu'à la prochaine fenêtre de
lancement c'est à dire dans deux ans
sachant qu'il ya beaucoup de pièces qui
vont devenir obsolètes dont savent aussi
rajouter beaucoup de coups on aura une
réponse pour ce programme là un d'ici la
fin de la semaine et puis il faut savoir
que l'ukraine est une puissance spatiale
aussi à l'époque de la chute de l'union
soviétique
on avait tout fait pour occuper les
ingénieurs russes soviétique et
maintenir dans les anciennes républiques
un programme spatial
la spécialité de l'ukraine c'est la
fabrication de moteurs il fabrique des
étages de fusées pour le lanceur léger
européen qui va donc lui aussi bientôt
être à court de pièces il fabrique
également des moteurs pour des fusées
américaines il fabrique des étages
entiers pour d'autres fusées elle aussi
américaine les fusée atlas ans qui sont
très utilisés depuis les états unis et
donc tout ça mis bout à bout font et
bien que tout le toute l'industrie
spatiale risque de connaître un énorme
coup d'arrêt ne serait-ce que mécanique
quelque part de par cette guerre là et
les sanctions qui en découlent merci
beaucoup
sylvain pour l'éclairage sur ce point
bien précis avant de refermer un